bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france pour quelles raisons selon vous
la diplomatie marocaine at elle choisi
d'afficher son soutien au droit à
l'autodétermination du peuple kabyle
quel message veut envoyer le maroc à
l'algérie
ces machines c'est manifestement un
choix tactique
le maroc que supporte mal la pression
que fait l'algérie pressions accrues ces
derniers temps pour une indépendance du
sahara occidental et par conséquent la
diplomatie marocaine de façon assez
surprenante d'ailleurs a choisi de
contre attaquer sur la kabylie alors
comme en effet journaliste vient de le
dire
le mouvement pour l'autonomie de la
kabylie est devenu il ya quelques années
un mouvement pour l'autodétermination de
l'acadie la kabylie c'est une une région
de l'algérie qui est peuplée de berbères
qui parle dans particulière question une
forte identité culturelle mais qu'il a
dit est berbère qui est beaucoup plus
vaste que la kabylie elle même n'a aucun
rapport avec le problème du sahara
occidental qui lui d'un héritage de la
décolonisation
c'était le sahara espagnol il a fallu
attendre la mort de franco pour qu' il y
ait un mouvement de décolonisation donc
en 1975
bien plus tard que le maroc bien plus
tard que l'algérie est aussitôt le maroc
a dit lorsque franco est mort mais ce
territoire est un territoire historique
qui revient au maroc et les gens qui
habitaient ces régions dont certains
étaient d'ailleurs d'aider des gens qui
bougeait d'un endroit à l'autre des
nomades et bien ont émis l'idée que
peut-être il faudrait avoir un
référendum pour demander si
l'indépendance était était était
acceptable
et puis ensuite eu un certain nombre de
conflits qui sont déroulées avec les
sahraouis et finalement le marocain
construit un mur
qui sait 2700 kilomètres ça n'est pas
rien et qui sépare en gros la ligne de
cessez le feu entre les troupes
marocaines et les sahraouis appuyé par
les algériens en 1991 80% du territoire
est contrôlé par le maroc et le reste
est bien est contrôlé par les sahraouis
et des paliers par les algériens
l'onu s'est mêlé de cette affaire il y a
d'ailleurs des troupes de l'onu sur
place et il ya une mission devenu le roi
du maroc ne s'y est pas trompé puisqu'il
a appelé la surdité rièzes secrétaire
général de l'onu pour lui laisser le
rassurer tout en disant qu' ils
pensaient qu'une solution politique
était était concevable mais dans le cas
du royaume marocain
l'ambassadeur du maroc à l'onu estiment
je cite que le peuple kabyle mérite de
jouir pleinement de son droit à
l'autodétermination
le maroc c'est face aux mouvements
indépendantistes du polisario dont le
but est d'accéder à l'autodétermination
du sahara occidental expliquez-nous ce
qui ressemble à une contradiction de la
part du maroc qui d'un côté soutient
mouvement indépendantiste et de l'autre
refuse la reconnaissance du polisario
oui ça peut sembler contradictoire
encore que le maroc a accepté de
discuter avec le polisario avec
l'algérie avec la mauritanie est que ces
discussions ont eu lieu sans résultat
jusqu'en 1999
donc ce n'est pas exactement la même
position parce que en algérie le
mouvement pour l'autodétermination de la
kabylie le mak a comme ils s'appellent
lui-même et bien et qualifié le
mouvement terroriste il est classé comme
un mouvement terroriste à alger donc la
situation est un petit peu différente
le maroc ne refuse pas le dialogue avec
le polisario
ce qu'il refuse c'est l'indépendance
réclamée par le polisario pour tout ou
partie du
sahara occidental donc je crois que les
deux situations sont tout à fait
différentes et que le maroc s'est un
petit peu aventuré dans cette affaire
pour trouver un argument tactique pour
faire réagir l'algérie s'est en effet
fait sur réagir l'algérie mais peut-être
que assez vite on en viendra à discuter
de problèmes plus sérieux
quelles répercussions discute cette
récente vive opposition entre l'algérie
et le maroc est ce qu'il faut par
exemple s'attendre à une plus grande
implication d'alger dans le conflit qui
oppose rabat aux indépendantistes du
polisario
oui sans doute mais l'algérie a son mot
à dire parce que l'algérie abrite des
réfugiés sahraouis du camp très
important qu'elle a toujours fourni une
une aide logistique voire militaires aux
sahraouis et par conséquent elle a
certainement son mot à dire
mais évidemment tout a évolué et
aujourd'hui l'algérie à de nouveaux
griefs à l'égard du maroc par exemple le
fait que l ceci que le maroc se soit
laisse entraîner par donald trump dans
la reconnaissance le d'israël
l'établissement ouvertures diplomatiques
avec israël compte une déclaration
suivant lesquelles le gouvernement des
états unis d'amérique
considéré que sahara occidental faisait
partie du maroc
ce que d'ailleurs joe biden s'est
empressé de démentir lorsqu'il est
arrivé à la maison blanche en disant que
où les états unis d'amérique comme
d'ailleurs pour les autres pays les pays
européens eh bien on s'en tient à la
position des nations unies puisqu'il ya
sur ce sujet des résolutions du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies et qu'il
n'y a pas lieu de s'en départir
ce qui implique que sans doute d'un jour
l'organisation d'un référendum
sauf si un accord amiable peut se
dégager auparavant et alors quelle est
la position de la communauté
internationale sur ce conflit et bien
justement la communauté internationale
pour l'essentiel je considère que c'est
la position officielle de le nul qui
doit prévaloir et que
eh bien il devrait y avoir un jour c'est
une forme ou sous une autre
une consultation des populations sur son
statut sur le statut futur du sahara
occidental alors le maran qui contrôlent
80% du pays depuis 1991 considère qu' il
est préférable de trouver une formule
d'autonomie dans le cadre du royaume
chérifien et que ceci est possible
ça va être difficile parce que le
phénomène générationnel j'ai aussi chez
les ch et les sahraouis et les jeunes
sont apparemment beaucoup plus combatif
que les anciens et c2 qui ont
probablement ses dernières semaines
alimenté les tirs qui ont eu lieu autour
du mur d'eau de 2700 km dont je parlais
tout à l'heure alors pour l'algérie est
aussi un enjeu important parce que pour
elle le sahara occidental c'est l'accès
à l'atlantique
l'algérie n'a également pas d'accès à
l'atlantique et des beaucoup de
commerces se fait par ce canal et elle
souhaite avoir une fenêtre sur
l'atlantique que lui donnerait
évidemment un sahara occidental
indépendant de façon symétrique est
opposée pour le maroc le sahara
occidental
c'est l'accès à l'afrique subsaharienne
et par conséquent à tous ces
développements auxquels le maroc attache
la plus grande importance
alors le maroc a pu réintégrer à pleurer
intégrer l'union africaine en 2017 alors
qu'il en était sorti en 1984
parce que l'union africaine avait
accueilli les sahraouis donc on voit que
les choses bougent un peu et
qu'aujourd'hui le maroc joue peu de son
poids économique et de ses relations
avec les états unis avec l'union
européenne pour essayer d'obtenir une
solution qui soit relativement proche du
statu quo mais cela prendra du temps
cela prendra évidemment les années et
évidemment le nez de rats joué un rôle
déterminant puisque tout repose sur des
résolutions du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies
il faut donc un consensus des cinq
membres permanents merci beaucoup pour
votre éclairage claude blanchemaison je
rappelle qu est un expert en relations
internationales